so okay I wanted 50-foot sea level rise
by 21 40 whatever I needed it as soon as
possible because I wanted to talk about
the financial crash of 2008 and how we
could do better next time so on the one
hand I wanted to be as soon as possible
in the future as possible on the other
hand I wanted 50-foot sea level rise the
IPCC at this point is saying that by the
end of this century CL of lives will max
out at like 1 meter so I had a
discrepancy there and lo and behold
James Hansen at all 18 co-authors 2016
paper while I was actually in the midst
of writing this book but obviously not
the passage I just read to you this
comes after the paper involved because
what the this rant does is pretty much
give you the results of this Hansen
paper what Hansen and his colleagues
wanted to say to the world is the IPCC
in attempting to be conservative in
attempting to say only something that
they can back up needed to give a quite
small figure for potential sea level
rise in the next hundred years and of
course history isn't going to stop in
hundred years but in any case it's a
conservative estimate and indeed you
know as far as we can tell in the last
hundred years you can measure sea level
rise in millimeters so it isn't as if
anything has happened yet I believe I
just this afternoon reading in Discover
Magazine so that between 1850 and now
sea level has risen about a foot so when
you're talking about 50 feet you needed
something and here's Hansen the economic
and social cost of losing functionality
of all coastal cities is practically
uncalculated adaptation will not work so
what he says in this paper with his 19
colleagues is actually a very strange
case it's cobbled together like a house
of cards and indeed if you pull out any
card the total house kind of falls to
the ground and so it's rickety and it
has been criticized and Hansen of course
now as a political figure
he's not just a scientist the NASA
scientist did all this great work he's
also the guy that laid down in front of
the tranqs in order to get arrested in
order to protest coal coal trains I
believe was what he laid down in front
of so when he writes a paper
and says look we've completely
underestimated the rapidity of sea-level
rise the suspicion of this paper was
extreme and the paper is rickety I would
be very interested to hear an analysis
by a real scientist because along the
way Henson will say well if thing if the
doubling rate of sea level rise goes
every 10 years you've got a certain rate
if it's 20 years you've got another rate
if you if you've got every 40 years
you've got another rate well anybody can
say that and it's true but there's no
evidence as to which rate we're on
because we're at the part of the graph
where things are just moving
horizontally and how the jump will
happen isn't is unknown to us right now
so he's doing an act of science fiction
and nonfiction form and that can be
challenged as such that factors many a
work of science fiction in nonfiction
form it's a genre
[Music]